(pleasant music)
- For 31 years I have been
acting in major motion pictures
and TV series, but you
may not recognize my face.
I'm Doug Jones.
I am an actor.
(pleasant music)
I got into acting out of a
need, almost, to be validated.
And it was at Ball State University that I
discovered the art of mime.
It was a very visual form of
communication and entertainment.
Little did I know that this would be early
training grounds for the career that I was
going to have in later years.
I had no idea.
After moving out to
Hollywood-land in March of 1985,
I'm thinking, “Okay,
now's the time to pursue
“this acting thing.”
My fourth booking was for
a McDonald's campaign.
That got my kinda hooked
into, oh, he's that tall,
skinny guy who wears stuff
and moves well in it,
and doesn't complain while doing so.
My first feature film was Batman Returns.
I got that audition because
of my contortive legs.
In the credits it says,
Thin Clown, which kind of,
it's kind of self descriptive, isn't it?
I have been in over 150 productions.
That would include everything
from feature films like
“Hocus Pocus,” “Hellboy” One,
“Hellboy II: The Golden Army.”
The faun in “Pan's Labyrinth”
was a page turning
career moment for me.
“Fantastic Four: Rise of
the Silver Surfer”; I played
the Silver Surfer.
“Star Trek: Discovery as Commander Saru.”
And most recently, “The Shape of Water.”
So when asked about how
long does the makeup take,
it, depending on the creature,
it can be anything
from a suit going on
and zipping up the back
or a makeup that is applied
to you from head to toe.
For instance, as Commander
Saru on “Star Trek: Discovery,”
it's around two hours a day,
which is mercifully short.
Flip side would be an Abe
Sapien from the “Hellboy” movies.
So that's one of the longer ones.
That took seven hours a day.
Wearing rubber bits that gets everything
that you think it would be.
It is hotter than you
want to be, it is heavier
than you want it to be,
it is more isolating
you can't always get access
to your naughty bits
to go pee if you want.
Why go through all of
this makeup application,
the time that it takes?
You can create monsters with VFX now.
I think people like to watch other people,
so even if that person
is playing a monster,
they wanna connect with
a human's interpretation
and performance of that monster.
It's old school cinema magic.
I kind of get the best of
both worlds when it comes to
being a public celebrity.
The bigger movies I've been
in, and the bigger things
that I'm known for, I look like this,
and then on the street, I'm
just a tall, skinny guy.
That's a gift.
Now that I'm in a movie
like “The Shape of Water”
with 13 Oscar nominations, I'm
getting recognized in public
a little bit more.
But it's still not to the point where I,
where I have people hiding
in my bushes, hoping
to get a snapshot of me topless.
That's not happening yet.
(pleasant music)